find a spot the lows oh that was crazy
damn it one more mix-up run away oh my
god Joe yeah here you go
tiny pixel it's gonna do a ton of damage
Oh cassabi oh I said three three sighs
oh my god lose the heads I'm gonna get
the round see that ladies and gentlemen
are you guys ready to watch a good ass
jacket
[Music]
guys welcome the second world tour
finals
lpq is about to begin it took me a
second night again I cannot believe it
is all led to this every road every
tournament every highlight that you guys
have seen has come from this amazing
amazing game and the voices that you
guys heard are all here in front of us I
got ripped I got my boy Rick's TV in the
building and the Deacon himself is
blessing us here in Thailand ladies and
gentlemen two DJ's margin Obama ladies
and dragons I'm glad you guys are
joining us it's about to be crazy The
Last Chance Qualifier is about to begin
we all have our favorite pics I'm
interested to know what do you guys
thoughts going into the LCQ anything can
happen anything can have it doesn't
matter is it gonna be Pakistan Japan
Korea USA Ricky you're an LCQ
unfortunately yes all right
are you serious how are we supposed to
choose anyone like we all decided to
choose two players Yeah right
and it was the hardest choice of our
line just two is two it's is I mean you
look at these pools and you look at the
path to top 30 to the top eight there's
it feels like there's 20 compared to
last year compared to the year before
the LCQ you know those were really
intense moments really especially last
year right really exciting finish girl
on the finishes with huge momentum going
into the next day but bro there's
something about this LCQ this year I
feel it hits a little bit different it's
kind of completely different gravity to
it yeah especially after the Year Tekken
that you had man you cannot deny the
energy in this room right now
it hits a little bit different this year
I'm gonna tell you right now I was just
talking to a lot of people out there now
out in the LCQ area and I was telling
them I was like taking one of the oldest
games on the tournament bracket at this
point but still has one of the highest
feelings especially considering we're
still getting new we're getting new
seasons of this game and we're getting
new players on top of it we got a whole
new country Pakistan to the ticket
Russell where people need to pay
attention to and I feel like that's one
of the most amazing things we have here
when it comes to ticket yeah Pakistan is
gonna be free DLC for a lot of the keep
my $4
yeah this is our first match coming up
this give me you know one of the
favorites here at the LCQ or one fan
favorite if people want to see do well
the LCQ gonna be you I use John dink
going up against a we've Maru from
Thailand I'm not familiar with Mari do
you guys know yeah we Mauro is a local
from the top from the Thai community
here yeah the comments are actually for
the tournament earlier this year
and that was another one you know with a
lot of it felt like with a lot of the
Asian challenger events right maybe they
didn't have the 200 plus numbers or the
300 plus numbers right but density comp
competitive density these were really
dense events actually you know at the
tournament earlier this year that was
one that arson ash one yep right
no definitely one of those things where
everybody started to pay even more
attention right right he was already
looking at the competition level here
but now it's went up even higher
considering what's happening with taking
this entire year and I feel like this is
the great way to end it up but this is
the first match Oh Julia I think so this
might still be a button check I hope
it's a boy
this is a button confirmation excuse me
button confirmations and like gentlemen
like real competitive players you're
going and you're d you think you took
control it's just not real he's picking
juice that's not real I don't believe
that for a second ah he's losing Julia
game brings out Julia LCQ surprise
surprise what you had I mean look it so
far it seems like he's doing fine but we
model in trouble right now back to the
wall okay yes you know we were at the
gym yesterday's team we saw John ding
there I asked him if he was gonna use
Chloe or Eddie he said
Julia no I didn't believe him wait you
really said that he said that I think
I'd really did not think he was gonna
actually do it
it's bloody great doing it but it's it
the whole back is working we know oh
goodness he missed the couch firm
we model making this a Julia pick not
looking like the best mm-hmm nice duck
dipper doesn't get a lot to the pop cake
mm-hmm Japs treats the mid-range right
now we Mars doing a good job of
establishing control extracts oh there
we go he's all we mobile kind of
scouting it a little bit Duncan girl you
try to set the face and he got him in
trouble back to the wall now and that's
the thing about Judah we talked about
like a DLC I feel like we didn't until
like the later half this year we started
to see Julian really break out we saw
rain to start pulling on the Julian
people started taking notice and I feel
like now it's crazy that we talked about
all these players all year picking
different characters to try to you know
matchup it make it a matchup game and
now we have employee Julia in the LCQ
and the game's been consistent in that
regard too man it's usually been the
characters get released they take six or
seven months to really develop and then
you start to see their impact on the
tour and on the meta like that it's been
consistently that way pretty much since
Tekken 7 star mm-hmm I feel like every
time a DLC Caird comes out everyone
underage then we're over yeah and be
like oh man this carrots not good enough
they don't have the tools and then as
you get written once I wait a second
wait a second that Nikken guys pretty
good no that's definitely true I like
punished oh and John think ever closer
okay
haven't you can talk I mean it still
feels like a little bit of character
like you know like inexperienced right
because ton that whip one is right there
with if he was Eddie that was that was
down for Nicholas for already locked in
but he'd let him whip and not do it and
he didn't do anything
instead of going to the business early
on oh yeah I don't know man maybe he
thinks it's like this has been a rough
year
huh I'm gonna have some fun out there
wait kicked I've never played before
yeah John thing in particular is to
really struggle to kind of be consistent
I think this year especially coming off
of his success the previous yeah I was
but that to me says a lot about the way
that the techadon has developed globally
when you have players like Tim and he's
not even alone there's seven other
players that are Tekken World Tour
finalists mainstays that are fighting
for their lives in this LCQ right he's
one of these one my first game working
out for Johnny I'm glad you said that
because as soon as you said like
comparing his previous success last year
coming in to 2019 we talked about Johnny
almost every tournament breakout
tournament wins out of nowhere and it's
just still being super consistent and
still traveling all year and trying to
like getting here now but I mean
gonna have to fight it out in this LCQ
we model you know in this pool right you
probably think Johnny's I'm gonna have
to play him at some point if it trying
to make it out and you're probably
packed super heavy your party packs for
Chloe so this now is kind of I mean he
told me he was gonna pick the kick guy
still gonna believe him right oh man
Game two no that's definitely that's
look everything that you guys have said
so far has been 100% correct the fact
that like ticket has been so consistent
when it comes to even like these top
tier players picking characters to try
to figure out how to how matches are
gonna work out those surprise tournament
picks we kind of criticize me we
criticize speed kick SoCal native but
yeah like these are all been things that
have been happening we've seen different
players we've seen speed
Jhin we've seen more coming from you
know players like me we've seen all
these matchups will be very much more
prominent and important going further
I'm so interested to see what that does
like for the LCQ we morrow with some
good defense that first round didn't
really take advantage of a lot of the
situations that he earned yeah right but
still able to keep together just like
you were saying earlier Ricky like this
is the cost of when you switch the
characters like this without that much
time especially in the game like Tekken
right you get you become kind of you're
not familiar yet with a lot of those
situations you have that wall bounce had
that range like that you saw John thing
not able to take advantage of it
as we morrow back to the wall right now
though I don't even know easy to be fair
this character is very scary at the wall
oh yeah I mean I feel like it's always
been that way - like vs. Julia and I
think that's really cool like they
announce that I don't want of this wall
this wall scariness is still gonna be
there and it's definitely she finds a
way to get to the wall on the infinite
stage just the messed up part I mean
definitely steal some of the best of
wall carry and just stage carry in the
game the shredders yeah that time you
know before you've dug too high and
didn't get the cool punish on it this
time you happy duck - got this where two
feet for the hob kicks so he's happy
he's like you know he's got some
tournament purposes new character yeah
of course I mean if you're not playing
your character in tournament right it's
in casual and in turn about two
different two different things if you're
not you know prepared to do what you
need to do with new character in the
clutch then it's it's tough John ding
staying on the winner cider this is this
thing what was it double it's double
right a single man that's all oh wait
this is a crazy off to keep it I think
it's crazy you're not good we good now
that would actually be too crazy
yes that's a scary game to play
Oh Chrissy that's right station B Chris
Creasy aka magneto ex from New Orleans
out here in limited Okinawa for a long
time in Korea as well the trap really
well travel Tekken player action god I
got the bounce now the doubt for three
consecutive Lee getting better and
better
like year in and year out we've seen him
make some great plays versus almost any
player that he's come up against no
matter you consider him some of the best
in the world best in the country and his
brother shadow
he's handled it's perfect when it comes
to a training part I'm feeling like a
lot of people don't look at jr. the way
they're supposed to because that dude is
ridiculous the other thing too is
compared to a lot of American players
he's really well traveled oh yes he's
been on his feet he's it's not even
about like you know does he get a have a
big performance this weekend I feel like
for him it's about it's a long-term
investment he's willing to go out there
to travel to grind yeah once again all
you like man that's guys the next
generation are taken for this country
that country along with Chado jr. one of
the next generation players for the unit
that's me that's America right now
absolutely huge shout out to disrupt
game of course supporting both those
guys and really bringing them along the
tour Chris Christie with the characters
like squit switched to Eddie this is who
he's been playing for the most part I
think instead that Tekken 7 yeah he was
on your team for the I would not be at
this table for a number this guy yeah
como estas
like all right game - yes yes okay wait
a minute wait a minute the backwards
movement piece with really good movement
not really trying to advance it off Oh
looking for the whip punished and there
it is now we yeah you know what time it
is Chris started this first matchup with
a blast especially considering with the
characters that's like he's John King
now all of a sudden gonna take a second
here to figure things out you know
juniors no stranger to the Eddy matchup
either
oh no of course I mean that comes with
how well he's travel he's deaf I don't
know he's played John Dean at least once
right yeah no he has some experience I
know for sure yes experience against
players like spear - I saw him nashi
there's so many big plays oh yeah she's
in the same pool as me she they're right
next to each other - actually that's me
she mentioned the both bank players
although net Albany she's now you know
he's been joining the dark side of geese
- smart man - and low touches right now
for crazy oh yeah that was my warmup
slow mode we're going out of the way
Reese if I went out of the way it's okay
no booze is yet and I was so unfortunate
for Kristy as well because because Eliza
was in the air so high that he crossed
her and crossed up after he got hit he
was ready to try to continue the combo
on top of that it was just the fact that
they switched sides
a second hit I hate that string shimmer
turn here decent carry as well season
three you know everybody goes to the
wall of a Dutch man set point now for
junior K rib no I'm just thinking deal
in the form an environment you can sing
a song why I love the jump off form and
I can just go full acapella
with a song in the commentary doesn't
stop it's perfect pick it eyes
that's perfect answer for the relax just
apply more divekick pressure jiggy he
didn't really show it at all game one
and then just pulls out the last two
rounds goes to the dive kick gain and
Chris Creasy now when losers junior
moving on winners side I feel like that
dive kick pressure from it lies is one
of those tools that a lot of people
aren't familiar with though and so you
can kind of just savor than lies the
player that it can cover up to play at
is Dan for that sinking and that's more
gold on one piece side as well oh wow
okay here we go oh nice nice almost got
[Laughter]
with the poker face keeping the glasses
on I respect it how can you play with
shades on like that man
look man just cuz you ain't that cool
don't go I just finish your is pretty
bright yeah it's gonna be a great
weekend we were just talking about like
young generations of players for
currency for countries right mogul
definitely will be representing that for
Korea as well
high impact Claudio player he's had some
really good performances on Tekken boat
or in the past two years yeah talking
about him to actually you know being a
threat to winning this either which is
kind of not not to disrespect him it's
more just like say like this is the
actual tournament it's that and also
he's a little bit less and well-traveled
than let's say whole song yeah it was
also kind of coupled with the motivation
play ticket you watch taken you know
about middle he and he could very easily
go off in this rack of course yes
looking like he's got his cost argue I
think about akin to he's got the
execution right so he's gonna fish for
and he like to be stylish all he she's
on sunglasses and suit you know he want
to hit that down for two electric that's
looks like all he can be aiming for to
be honest and they just gonna start
helping like he won p2 waked alright
that's we are out here army you know
it's like you didn't really give a king
strategy where you just gave every
kazuya close it out Mogo trying to put
himself in good position to close out
this first game not really give me a cup
too many chances flash points conway
cried again some started first one of
the game
here we go away kit okay so that's why
you can't for that and the hop kick to
crush the Japs mouth was open afterward
you know that's no good
the way those those uh those astral
headsets fit on on his neck it almost
looks like a neck brace
yeah it's like one of those travel
pillows yeah multi-use we got to get
them like two or three you pull the
Chris G oh nice bag them up yeah there's
been a car accident or something yeah
you gotta make sure your eyeballs here
as well as your ears and your shoulder
blades audio clarity and it takes care
of the neck I've never actually seen
anybody pick it in tournament I know
we're learning like all the different
outfits still right because they're all
introduced in season three right oh wow
what all these presets who knows I may
come through with the tailored suit
let's go
this looks like a regular night out for
these two guys to the roof I'll see you
outside bucko the biggest side bits
inside that helicopter
hey are you trying to get away from the
wall not today
no you waking them up ooh you waking up
akin you want some bacon sweet
Ricky was right everything's your plan
they get that one round of confidence
and then if I okay yeah I'm just go home
now
you have to man but don't think it's big
dog big nuts style kazuya man that's the
only way you play that character
Oh second it delayed with the wall
pressure here
third round gain to it man this is first
round round take god I didn't realize
it's round one where's like every LCQ
has been actually ridiculous
yeah love the delay technical mogul
didn't get up so you can have a deal -
Oh cuz I mean oh Christ
Oh God pullout games so strong right he
delayed it a little bit let's go honking
oh my god I'm gonna be so bruised by the
end of this I told you man I could have
taken that side up it's all right Ricky
your dick now you always grab to your
left I see he's got that homing attack
the mid every single time but here we go
final round situation moko trying to
close it out and you can tell he caught
on to the fact the egg is trying to
sidestep together
flash punch combo slash kick it out okay
duck
he didn't duck it every single time Bell
yeah the bounce oh hey double lows yeah
and he switched up his wall pressure
that time from what you guys were saying
before right
a lot of good needs to be in his homing
attack to people trying to steal Akins
movement at the wall like that that time
he goes low mix it up and it was enough
to close out the game close up set the
John definitely nominated tasty player
the flat out of the year for like one
round was it was over I'm just saying
look it's more to it than just that it's
the fact that he's playing martyr that's
what it is the fact that he's playing
his character and he's still doing super
well with it he's consistent definitely
thing is this has to be one of the I
think the high impact players that a lot
of people have picked to me yeah to
truck easily may be able to get out to
sell CQ for sure yeah like you said he
it feels like he's only had
international eyes on them for such a
very short amount of time but in like a
month right we went from not knowing
anything that John who the hell is that
everybody's got their eyes on this guy
right I just like pausing when I say his
name the top you gotta say it like that
it's way too good of a player not to put
some respect to my man's name another
you know I said nothing against hearts
in action I'm saying the fact that he
came out of nowhere playing Marduk and
made and made a statement and stuck to
it on top of it the fact that he's here
and I get to see him in person that's
why I was really happy to see the
Pakistan players cuz I didn't get the
gold its back we haven't metalhead
godlike time there I saw that that was
her Dubai was pretty tight that was a
really touching
I what what I'm saying is where the
Americans at what do you Merrick is that
look at this trophy dome that looks like
CG trophy right there bro it's real
though it's upstairs I saw it with my
own eyes that's eSports baby how they
look I feel like you got to give them
lights to properly display that no man
is LCQ come on
one thing I can't get to the other one
family couple so this is the Stanley
couple to take a ridiculous actually
that's crazy
no we got two or $50,000 for the price
point to the trophy yeah maybe
okay here we go oh we got the
Philippines doujin here oh nice
hey you know actually it's like the
filipino players like dojin in a cave
right they haven't they haven't traveled
as much this year feels like and so I
think that they still have a very very
good shot of making the finals they just
have this is the hardest path possible
so you say that like that's true right I
feel like the dojo system is actually
really really made that the case right
cuz other years like all the Filipino
players they would actually have to
travel far and out of the way outside of
like something like real major which is
an amazing tournament but the dojo
system and shout out staccato um made it
so these guys can get more points and
have a better shot of getting into the
tech world tour finals but still not
able to close out gonna be hearing as
LCQ and dojin I've been telling people
for years man I've always been a fan of
dojin and the fact that the Filipino
players are so strong the entire region
is ridiculously strong actually so yeah
especially for the first I'd say six
months of the tour this year they were
the ones that kind of stood out with how
hard they went in on that dojo system al
he's whining in the Philippines and they
had they even have their own events and
an elite structure out there - man they
go there they really been going nuts and
it's you know to be honest with you uh
you said they haven't been as well
travel this year but actually they've
been traveling quite a bit out here in
Southeast Asia Japan and they because of
that yeah for sure for sure
then they definitely had their
opportunities uh kind of finished a
little bit short I think it's some of
the master events they've been able to
make some big impact than some of the
challenges here and there but like you
said not able to get it done gonna be
one another one of these high impact
players from especially the Philippines
right we're looking at him in a que ever
trying to get some work done in the
south and salsa q
definitely one of my favorites two of my
favorites they very well could like put
everybody on steal it mister oh yeah and
that's hottie he behind the competative
from the from Red Mage mm-hmm you see
that sure he got me one of those shirts
too if there's a lot of support they
maybe got I can't remember his name
right now but all the red major guys are
here to support all the players for the
Philippines as well so I mean you know
the only thing I've heard about about
rep Ranger and the Filipino crowd is
that they are the best crowd real when I
tell you rev major is one of the most
amazing tournaments especially when it
comes to Tekken yeah man it's beautiful
and here you go you have a player like
dojin who you know who's raised in a
that's where he plays and everybody
there's so many good players in the
Philippines so I'm glad that we have
some representation especially in the
form of dongjun like I said definitely
one of my favorite players to watch but
here we go you have a character
representation to write you don't see
large to that much the second seven
especially not since console release I
mean he's one of the very few that's
been representing him on this on this
level
deftly said that he's always been at
omar's main even when he's just playing
Shaheen knows a lot of times he news
chin he was his best character and this
character that bet received a lot of
benefits and buffs and in season 2 and
season 3 yeah definitely a much more
competitive character that this is
there's a lot of characters especially
in Asia really strong rats that you just
don't see a lot of people playing yeah
and he is definitely one of the ones
that goes with this terrain and thing
about that regard you go back to like
lashes LT key ones go Londo on you know
Katarina was just one of those
characters and that sort of a position
where you know she had been to subscribe
she had seen a little bit of it but the
battle to kick the wall in the
tournament the good news same thing here
where it kicked like large pulls through
oh no
[Music]
yeah it's funny you brought up red
nature you brought the Filipino crowd
something yesterday in interviews when
you ask no bean what was his favorite
moment from twt this year he said
obviously break out the world what a
text wrap that was nicer I'm glad don't
you made that last round super fast yeah
here the least amount of it shot us at
Oh Jude pick the outfit made it quick
maybe he uses that as self motivation as
well as like you maybe he hates the song
as much as we do
hi or soon as I gets a follow-up that's
it Oh like one stays in the target I
would prefer that song you know maybe
hammerhead guys got some work to do here
I mean he was first never he definitely
did that rage or I dropped I was really
what got him costly yeah I mean told you
look here we haven't seen his laws in
turn to me it feels like you quite some
time and it it looks super super strong
right now yeah like he said in a lot of
the agencies usually been he's been in
the eliminated off stream that feels
like most of the time yeah that's so
true
here we go he had a big change the
largest written is the return of is hold
down for two right yeah except now it's
full crouch down forward to put still
safe I read watcher Oh with the whip
punish his would punishing great block
off to sidestep wait a little I'm around
yeah we do stop listen to it where will
acquire kicks a thief though Jude's
entire approach to this game to write a
lot of mid posts on a low folks and that
just instantly fact fashion waiting for
a response try to take advantage of the
wind punish after you can see that a lot
people to go back a [ __ ] duck
immediately so the outer range submits
there's really dangerous he gets a lot
of good low block like that yeah that
wasn't even like a wood once I was just
like you run again here we go choir the
electric guitar - 50% backs off not try
to over pursue
told you no we're talking about lawyers
here bro
he'll spin one time he's got five more
moves you hitting that wall bro
nice job therefore dojin gonna be moving
on winterside there i think we are Hey
look it looks like you already won
no man no spoilers man oh never mind
did we did with one ok - here I'll begin
it's chibi Kim Jae peepers JP Bert your
first round Japan vs. Japan I like those
Brad yeah yo G boy I mean you know he's
always been a gigas mane and it's like
the guinness mean guys are though are
the most committed ones right like they
feel like they really love this
character i mean the real tragedy is it
feels like in big stages they always get
grouped together and they have to kill
each other early on yeah and the
brackets right but at this point you
know the tekken 7 is coming up on 5
years old it feels like the gigas play
if you're still playing gigas in 2019
you're a character specialist at this
point oh yeah and the thing is this camp
is not very popular you can get away
with a lot of stuff isn't it and get
away with it a lot of stuff that's
definitely true especially what the way
this character play is right in really
emphasizing his [ __ ] rage is able to
stand in a range a range one where
you're outside of most other character
jabs but then he has the threatening
power of his 1 - that's a very smart
thing to say right because the jab is
such like a pivotal tool about mind
control the pace and space right and the
fact that your voice uses a character
like
control their range a little better than
most says a lot but here we go cheap you
can actually taking their round away but
yeah like taken and that's why I said
it's one of the oldest games on any
tournament bracket right now right no
matter what tournament you go to taken
to be in there it's really really cool
so you get these characters specialists
that have a lot of experience they got a
lot of the things if you don't know how
to fight them just because they're not
that popular you're gonna get beat up
right rip yes got beat at the master Cup
right I'm pretty sure it was another guy
but I'm pretty sure it is this guy every
every every gigas player Jojen boy you
heard here everyone every last one of
them yeah you guys called three
different you Yoji boys they're all
different
Yoji boy style too right he really he
plays it like you let me said before
right outside that jab range but it's
not like he's always trying to force
hard mix up there's a lot of just poke
heavy right jab down pour one down back
to and then trying to go in for grabs up
that down too as well look for the
launch oh you know almost closed out
there around nice little Perry og boy oh
boy - zero gonna be moving on and Yoji
boy also of pro license holder now from
earlier this year right yes that was one
of the stories in Japan right last year
got gay kept by a cocky knocked this
player right and the big thing is uh
yeah like yo gym boy like you said
before is he's from Osaka right they
don't have a lot of opportunities out
there they don't have a lot of big
events you know prizepool the tournament
stuff like that that's not something
that they have out there that platform
and that ability that potential for
exposure is really big deal for him so
he won it this year and he let everybody
know about he was really happy with yeah
and look at this I musician coming up
next you guys know you want to see some
of that of course music versus you did
boy bands running the gauntlet rip I'm
gonna give you some advice because I've
been there you
they KKK me
I've already been canceled me okay are
you came come on I'm already a
syndication let's right put him at the
wall I musician this is one of the
nasties the oh she plays on planet Earth
[ __ ] he's definitely like this is a
character specialist right here yes Yosh
if you can talk about gate this used
less than Jesus it has to be used
especially at this level on these kinds
of stages right also yeah he's a cattle
player from Tokyo area as well he comes
to fighting Tuesday a lot okay please
everything but hi musician I think what
shines about him to me is his duty he
knows when to go ham and he has a lot of
youth Lakers its Yoshi right the bag of
tricks is really deep but then he
compliments that really woman is really
really smart you know all that was Bob
like that was so sick dancer it'll
absorb it and the god something music
for your eyes your company music for
your eyes don't stick down to Abu with
the compost gorgeous
Oh chopper style with the Gameboy goes
the I musician this has to be this has
to be another player that I think God a
lot of people kinda have their eyes I'm
especially going the top 32 he's
especially important because in theory
right Yoshi players can pose a big
threat to the Akuma play in theory right
I believe him in just from James and
Dubai they got matched up with a teapot
in pools and there were some very close
sets there and especially considering
that I think a teapot has to be one of
the favorites that people are looking at
the windows LCQ yep
if he's able to make a deep run that
shake things up I think
how did just frame James even feet I'm
musician that's Matt we didn't get to
see in Dubai not on street would
happened it happened though that's
because pay-per-view may start something
with stuck something to the channel oh
now he's messing around it's always
messing around you watch I'm a musician
though oh she's like minutes do plan any
percent of that damage is all
unblockable
he was holding back and he lost 80% of
his health thank you didn't try to go
further down for what let's do
so like I didn't know that Yoshi was
actually saying words a lot of the time
you know saying is this a sword a lot
look o know if it's feel in this game
but you don't have to have the replays
and like taking six right whenever you
do and what the guarantee I paid a
special get so look
that was definitely a guaranteed thing
that he hit a pump we just saw last time
but the accident official kiddo got out
of the way and steel lost around this do
I musician is a step ahead of the game
every oh man he now he's threatening
suicide I don't scary threat don't make
me do it kill myself come on bro you
might die first just puts it into the
banjo put the sword into the banjo
good for him as well here whilst the
first time he's actually looked like his
height every time I see I had musician
on stream and he sits down he looks like
he's four feet tall yeah baby stands up
and he's like six feet six 11 like
what's one of those players I mean just
for me I always respect them cuz he what
he runs the camogie they came out came
out of course I'm pretty sure I said
this over like a [ __ ] wanna love ya
this has to be I think one of the guys
you look you look to as a favorite right
in fact I mean you see that whiff
Cornish dude that's one of the things
but it has done so well throughout this
entire basically this entire tours his
wit punishing has been so good with the
scary you of all people know right like
it feels like we're maybe a lot of the
other players that represent this
character at that level where they might
leave some damage on the table it's
optimized every time yeah there it is
right they he's not dropping anything
got just enough to be able to close out
you saw mr. recall he was trying to do
something on every get up and you know
about was just like nope I see it nope I
see it yeah he's ready for everyone
right about a teeth but see but is
definitely one of those players I've
been looking at um we all talk about
like the Akuma threat right we talk
about it but the fact of the matter is
there are better players with a [ __ ]
right a team is one of them I mean to be
honest with you if you're Saint who I
think I didn't 19th spot on this on the
lead boy right well and of course he did
what he had to do in the in Dreamhack
Atlanta but it felt like he dodged a
bullet man if a cheap one to one if if
he was able to let's say go to Dreamhack
and even get like to fourth place third
I mean you're looking at a completely
different situation there you know but
what he had that one small mr. Brydon
Dubai yeah he looked like he took it a
little too lightly is playing on the
character of the pool metaphor low high
low is like you're I've been preparing
for you just on some Terminator stuff
but I swear to God when he did that one
demon flip and he just queued up the
suit he was already standing up out of
the chair before we even knew what yeah
I'm gonna hang out I saw that and he
talked about it too right low high in
particular that has to be played of
that's we're gonna talk about tomorrow
right that's one of the players that
everybody has to kind of have their eye
on because motivation and because of the
way he trained way he played he went
into that tournament he played a coma
for three weeks
that was sick I mean look if you
he takes it
soda heart like he loses and he goes
straight to Twitter's like you know what
I need to be better about these things
and I'm glad you said that man I mean
it's something like that's something
that came up a couple weeks ago - right
the Saddam twit longer and he talked
about yeah right maybe compared to some
other players what makes a little high
special is he's not afraid to take that
out oh not afraid to take that out and
it will weigh on him but in a he will
come back much stronger and he will come
back and he will have the solution ready
next time why did you do that he's like
well I didn't feel my workout was deep
those are the kind of thing yeah that
makes him let's know he's always trying
to go up but here we go
we have you know Massa Q versus Redman
yeah baby baby oh damn Japan first Korea
once again in credit isn't nothing one
of those players what he's roughly like
24 25 years old right another one of the
Claudia made something fun and use been
around forever second place at evo 2005
what let's talk let's go let's go way
back then you know his other name though
may mister no respect character got a
lot of decent buffs in season three as
well you know a lot from just minor
frame and ban changes but the wall
carries good now the wall calm was
different unfortunately still not a lot
of representation but he was one of the
legacy players in this character okay
he's never he's never stripped
out of his you in particular I think
it's kind of an interesting case -
because if I compared to maybe two or
three years ago he's a lot less
prominent now yeah but when he doesn't
travel as much right but especially the
Asian stages he's had some really
high-impact performances and some of the
Challenger and master events earlier
this year with you - it's like we all
remember that one year master cup where
he just like everyone was like oh he was
the weakest member of that team and then
he's the one that did the most grand
finals yeah he's the one that activated
that that used to be made now it's a
high alert I mean I don't know if he was
like yo love this is definitely high now
or that was a stupid move or who's made
I made a rant about that now it's high
let's go and what I really like about
the Amasa squad too is you know I mean
it's obvious when you watch right book
it
they're always by each other whenever
they're competing no bee is not even
playing today right yeah buddy of course
he's right there right talk si he's
right there by you side there's a sense
of karate camaraderie there that is uh
really really helpful I think is if
you're if you're a player by yourself
and it's totally different when you got
somebody behind you giving you advice
being a birthday you know calm you down
make you feel good about competing about
the is the fact that like they've always
been like a clear like even before they
had a name they were always playing
tackle together making each other
stronger and look at what it's done
legacy was there's still some of the
stronger players in the world
can't take that away it was the same
thing before the jerseys and after the
support you know you talked about like
how the team tournament takes weeks up
and out of the players is different
right because you play for something
more than yourself I think just having
your teammates there beside you does the
same thing oh yeah yeah look around I
look right at Ricky don't look at me
well you're the backhoe back turn sweep
and you can steal that round taking a
big risk there to upender all that
sweeping jab float here couple there I
like that able to cash out a little bit
more than expected at profane as well
the shoulder at the wall Oh pull out
game not that strong
just not overextending at all you know
what you starting to hit but we got hit
by the hop King and now he's backing up
giving them a perfect space escape just
outside the range of the Superman punch
didn't even have to risk ducky it just
stayed right out of range you was
playing ridiculous today yeah wait wait
wait to a person right there he had to
try it out all right rip me back in the
game he's stayin alive first round in
the entire set every pole kid tried
right there too but luckily he was on
the floor tried it again
nice try on the wit partition that was
that was a heavy-duty meeting to be
careful because they only raised not an
issue here for you ready to go though
going in hit on with the blatant Lowell
stills
another round this is Game two nice duck
and punish there you go got the launch
at this time haven't understood man
here's the wall afterward bomb inside
right back at the start here at center
stage I could do it to the drive lots of
blocks go over the wall though the wall
one to close out for you haka classic
Claudio setup since detective 7.0 but
didn't pull the trigger that time we
would have war it is the cray stick but
you getting the victory look really
sharp throughout the whole set Daniel
where's Joey
yeah Jewry stormed hey we used to see
him a lot at the strong Styles back in
the day he was living in a sudden got 40
for a little bit back in tech 5dr days
you know but you know is Daniel motto
his name Julie Madhu sounds so much
sweeter it sounds like it's kind of
quirky yeah I think about mr. Magoo the
cameraman get off you bring up Daniel in
particular righty
it hasn't been too too active outside of
the EU tournaments Pro Second World Tour
that you have with that's kind of
deceiving because he's actually super
well travel he came out to Japan for
like two or three months earlier this
year just to travel around he went to
Korea Tekken matches as well yeah he was
actually doing really well the training
out there paid off for him for sure a
lot of experience I didn't know he went
to the Masters though in Korea no he
came out there for like two or three
months man pretty much one of tissue
Mons disciples right took his advice
he's like hey man if you want to go out
there play co-op then play yeah he
didn't he took it to heart Mandy came to
what several fighting Tuesdays went to
Korea Tekken masters I think the Osaka
Challenger as well Wow he's definitely
been moving tied up one-one now as going
to sook one of those character loyalists
always been rocking Mina forever another
one of the Thai players to menu you it
feels like we've kind of written an
awful lot of these players out here but
you gotta remember book is fighting for
his life in this LCQ you gotta remember
his school you have a reaper rabbit you
have that's true community is kind of we
always go to the wall from the window up
[Music]
that's why I asked you kinda hit pick up
here once again I'm in my heart I just
don't want it to you don't know but do
a little bit of a rough spot there two
foot cleaned it up in that third game
nice job there I think he had a really
good sense also for Julie storms timing
and intention at a given moment right if
I like a lot of times especially in that
second round you could sense the
desperation I just want to push him to
the wall I just want that wall pressure
especially Nina players you know they
did thirsty little blocks really yeah a
lot of times just like stop moments have
you seen the inner players just you know
what I need to get you saw him do just
that in the second round right just
queue it up just want me to think about
it
no I was pretty smart but look guys
we've already played a lot of taken to
begin but we have more but it's gonna be
right after this break guys don't go
anyway